what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch a film that I'm
sure is extremely Advertiser friendly for
YouTube by all stretch it's a film called
X and I've never seen the trailer but I know
it's 8 24. I know my homegirl Jenna Ortega's
in it what's her name Mia goth she's at all
the talk and I'm like yeah so very blunt reaction
today have you seen a trailer for this I saw
like an ad a long time ago I know like a couple
Bare Bones ideas but not much else I'm excited
to see what's in store how are you I am excited
I've been hearing a lot about this so I can't
wait to see what's in store um but yeah guys
thanks for uh recommending this our way please
go ahead and leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click that
notification Bell because you never know what
we're going to cover on here then I pique
your interest also uh full-length Reaction
watch along as we single with your own copy
of X we are watching this off Amazon available
for or super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page thank you to all who joining we cover
several stuff exclusively over their reaction
highlights and watch alongs included all right
I'm I I don't know what we're about to watch
let's find out
[Music]
as Zack Snyder intended oh this is a clever
shot are we through a doorway oh good call
yeah I love Texas Chainsaw oh that's clever
yeah nice [Music] perfect aspect ratio change
yeah
Oh I thought that was an animal
wow that's exactly the Texas Chainsaw house
I regret to say I know the powers of Satan
Amen brother
creepy
nice transish satanic undertones and some
very overt satanics
[Music] cool shot you're special there ain't
nobody else out there like you I feel like
that line is very important already you're
a [__] sex symbol [Laughter] that's what
that's how I start my day
digging the framing a lot
plowing
service [Laughter]
don't worry [__] and text America America
don't tread on me
very Texas Chainsaw The Farmer's Daughter
Hollywood here we come to no man we don't
need Hollywood these type of pictures turn
regular folks into Stars we're gonna do it
all ourselves this guy does a great McConaughey
impression so it sounds an awful lot like
what you said about the topless Car Wash you
remember that yeah and head the IRS shut up
I was still a good hand people spent a lot
of money to look at what God gave me is that
Britney's no that is Brittany Snow and that's
Kid Cudi oh what Jesus [Music] Hurry Up We're
Not Gonna Be Long in there
man these set designs are really great I deserve
and I think I have Cosmopolitan take don't
I know it I mean it all in the whole world
don't know my name everyone with a pulse is
going to lust after a piece of Mexican makes
they see what you can do all right I've seen
Minx because you're gonna be all over the
news lady your little boyfriend's cute you
help him with all his films sometimes yeah
is that your boyfriend sometimes [Laughter]
actually intend on experimented a lot with
the films editor giving it a certain sense
of the iPhone card like they're doing in France
it's classier that way oh yes elevate your
material all right go ahead and fill her up
so very good direct Cinema If you tilt the
camera up from the nozzle it'll look like
he's using his symbolism
I mean you shouldn't expose your jacket then
exactly something I want to advertise around
town there's some Evangelical backdrop is
very interesting get what we needed well I
got it thanks thanks to Yours Truly oh my
God there's Sinners that are going to be punished
yeah God's gonna come down himself I appreciate
even with the sound design they're really
committed to it
still a TV station that's the whole state
watches jeez yep [Music]
but every man has got his limits oh look at
all these cows interesting are they gonna
kill all these cows yep I love cows there's
a cow up close I love them
what
[Music] maybe just one oh no
let him go foreshadowing oh that's horrible
I'm getting too old for this [__] something
tells me it's gonna really take a very change
of like very attention a very big change into
Russian damage damage you got there it's like
oh Texas Chainsaw but then now it's really
gonna take a change
foreign
voyeuristic angles too very 70s makes you
want to bust out your zoom lens y'all stay
put while I go and handle business right quick
it's choir music sounds like sacrificial music
yeah foreign
because it is possible to make a good dirty
movie
it's a good fight my dude read it for the
articles are you from the county this year's
private property didn't you see the signs
down at the end of the draft oh easy partner
yeah no cues I'm from Houston now we spoke
on Tuesday oh that's right uh you had me pretty
nervous there it ain't even unloaded that
that's one of this song [__] wow we don't
even see that guy up close huh I wonder if
it's some kind of Easter egg character actor
and I'll probably see him again but Charlie
Hunnam yep
what if it just turns into the visit
oh you know that's the devil right there you
got sin walking on your property right now
lady Temptation incarnate won't be having
any of this lust and fornification over here
we are a wholesome family God's children you
sure flat feet I did two tours in South Vietnam
had enough Farmers trying to shoot me for
one lifetime just like that you made it out
of me yeah I don't recall you mentioning you'd
be bringing all these others see your head
said thirty dollars but
little extra Sweeting the deal I'll take your
35 dollars that's a very sweet deal
harmless he's just old he don't know what
we're doing does he was the glass of course
not he sure doesn't and I intend to keep it
that way what's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission sir God damn dead body
in there what's with all the Flies
cut to the Chase and we give people what they
want to see finally [Laughter] Kid Cudi I
wonder what the audition was like so you know
if you're watching this on YouTube all of
this is gonna be a lot of it you can't see
right now
I can't tell if Jenna Ortega is enjoying it
or not yeah no she she wants she secretly
wants this life
sloshing water go for a dip what could go
wrong now we're on Friday that they're charista
Lake
oh is that the mom had the wife I mean yeah
probably got more hair on top oh [__]
is she the villain of the movie is it the
visit but damn sure damn [__] on there
well that's because I'm not treating a lot
of pornography but it's Cinema people's eyes
are gonna pop out of their damn skulls when
they see this foreshadowing oh wow that's
a that's a workplace scenario
strange inner cutting because back then they
couldn't it took a long time to add like a
dissolve yeah I just put a few friends okay
oh good when your feet were in the water I
was like I wonder if an alligator would be
in here and then it becomes crawl or a crocodile
a very cool shot yeah it's spooky
that is a terrifying shot oh damn oh that
is terrifying all their budget went into building
this alligator
a team of puppeteers
no no no no no no no no
my daddy will be home soon and I'm sure he
could give you a lifts down would you like
to come inside ah would I this is like a French
man yeah absolutely watch a guitar or truffo
you know
what is that
is she being waved over yep follow me Deary
just making some fresh head cheese
hello
that made me jump
I find this all very interesting
a lot of flies in here too [Laughter] it's
all sweat everyone's just sweating oh damn
we might actually have a dead body this time
or a disgusting sink yes it's like every haunted
maze I've ever been to
oh what a tea party
yeah I was young ones too I'm just taken right
before the first water not even or not my
hours served them both damn that sucks there
wasn't anything you went through for me back
then acrossed oceans of time to get to you
and the war games not everything in life turns
out how you expect this could be your future
lady you remind me of me beautiful [__]
[Music]
guys gotta stop hanging by the windows I wonder
why we're intercut into this daddy catches
us there's no telling what he might do [Music]
what are you doing
just in time
it'll be our secret
yeah right yeah it's okay something tells
me that woman's evil yeah and he's actually
all right he's as protective the rest of us
foreboding music oh my God the kid says we're
going to lose a lot come on now Chop Chop
well she's definitely in the mood now yeah
get on camera
not except love I do not deserve so many mantras
in this movie so much lust and greed man Pride
they are the embodiment of the seven deadly
sins except for gluttony they're all in good
shape
laughs oh oh evidence
oh no oh you guys don't go sneaking
this is pretty very this is pretty like artsy
it's good I could give you a ride
whoa huh ew oh it's quite a vanity
it's bad news come on old lady get in there
yeah she wants to jump in she curious
she also wants to jump in
that is creepy as hell oh yeah she craves
the youth
oh oh that's you in the future embrace it
I have a weird Theory I wonder if that old
lady isn't it is like a a younger a much younger
actor in makeup like it's her like it's me
a goth or something [Music]
I wonder if she relied so much on her beauty
foreign go for it let's do this seduce Him
Live your best life you know I can't my heart
oh but what a way to go out careful tell y'all
she was something special thanks baby
oh come on don't be so shy speak up say you
want to be in the film as you wear your crucifix
foreign
watching her doing it with him as long as
the camera is running so the camera changes
things that's right it's not real life Randy
it's just a movie I'll run this by my wife
yes absolutely maybe with anyone I want if
there's a camera decide who you want to attraction
healthy keeping those feelings locked away
inside I've seen you sneaking a few long Peaks
at Jackson over here no I I wasn't looking
you don't mind none oh no he's insecure cameraman
mines finally people gonna get to see what
datas are and the privacy of their own homes
oh yeah free of judgment we're going to give
that to them before anyone else on betamax
host of the perverts they've been paying our
bills for years living a lot of access being
young and however on to the day we die to
the power of Independence Cinema thank you
I don't know if I agree with all of that but
I did like what I saw today I think I would
but I did cheers to that
where is this Sequence gonna land us yeah
oh splatterfest what awful montage is this
beginning
this poor old lady she's so old and has so
many desires still us I want to do a scene
in the movie oh here it is yep yep who's gonna
do the sound
what
no did y'all put her up to this or something
oh yeah it's your fault man yeah I mean it
wouldn't make any sense we've already shot
half of it story can't just suddenly change
Midway just add another daughter why because
it just isn't done what about on psycho you
love that movie well psycho is a horror film
and you're about to step into one nobody's
coming to see this film for the plot
plot and a big
oh man you just signed her death warrant Jenna
Ortega she's gonna do it whether you like
it or not now you try to stop her not only
is she going to do it she's going to go on
and do it with God knows how many people and
God knows how many other films and nobody
wants that
the rain is not like the others in there she
is a nice girl wow thank you pardon no I didn't
mean it like that I hate to be the one to
tell you this girl
[Music] set up a tripod and get on screen
dude damn what an uncomfortable last position
of being [Music] there it is man Satan rains
down his influence you signed your death warrant
oh dude's crying dang
dang no you would not survive 2023 buddy yeah
man you will not survive the only Fan's era
I wonder if he's the other one who makes it
out of here alive I could see it or he's about
to die or the first one to die let's see how
far they get without me good luck finding
your own way honey
Don't Fear the Reaper [Music] oh why'd you
get out are you all right
what's behind her hand sorry I'm oh
[Music] make her dreams come true son get
back at Jenna Ortega uh what's in her other
hand
hope the husband doesn't see this gonna get
his head blown off how come you just did that
I mean like you looked at her I can show you
what okay stop I I don't want to see it
oh it's poor old woman maybe we should just
go find your husband that's not the solution
or leave leave oh yeah yeah you were right
should have said yes
whoa
disturbing
foreign oh my God whoa cool lights lighting
change
oh buddy ah
God that is so many I mean I wonder how many
slashes they had to cut that down from this
is what happens to me it's what happens when
you're a controlling prude when you say no
she needs to let it out somehow maybe she
can reverse the aging process with his blood
to how you used to dance yeah she's Arthur
Fleck
I'll go crawl inside the fridge
oh RJ
RJ
I'm sorry she started slaughtering all them
old ladies finding her youthful energy again
I woke up and he was gone I think he left
me do you oh huh he's probably just processing
things you know come back to bed what if I
heard him I want to break up
will you help me find him please cause I'm
worried I ain't getting in the middle of no
more in this [__]
see we got shoes on
what are you doing out here looking for my
boyfriend have you seen my wife sir all right
now you two get together
two keys keeping a healthy relationship
never let a good woman out of your side I
never mentioned her weight there's an art
to it just like business yo no good oh oh
man no oh
wow wow damn it's cool to do one take
me Christ's sakes I'm Gonna Catch tennis from
the [__] sure
all you gotta do is do it with the old lady
it's the key that's how you survive it right
what is that
it's gonna be like a pitchfork or something
yep
not bad there's another light down on the
cellar you go get it my wife is not well it's
very dark and I'm worried she could fall and
break her hip yeah that's that's what you
should be worried about faster you go about
it the better
whoa whoa transitions
oh it was an eye out that was a really good
jump scare
oh is she moving quick yeah she's getting
agile why will none of you make love to me
I think she's found a new outlet yep
two there you go stab away lady and make sure
he's dead there you go enjoy yourself
I'll get another poke in there
poke him in the butt [Laughter]
I think you're right I think there is a reason
there's so many flies all over this Farm
damn she home alone in them what if instead
of a little kid it was an old person found
it hey I'm locked in
damn
open up
the music is just like heavy panting [Music]
whoa no yeah it's a reasonable reaction what
a reaction
oh yeah it is just M2 in the house huh no
no it's me a pharaoh too me a Gothia and me
a pharaoh somewhere in this universe sure
absolutely those raised babies in the 70s
right my wife it's gone missing what a far
powerful I'm missing why it's for Gators I
found her once by the edge of our pond she
used to fall in yikes want some help
oh God
yeah I'd do that maybe some shoes too he did
that scene method too
[Music]
this film is scary yeah really ominous and
unsettling
go lie in bed with her tell her how you feel
you touch her skin
waiting for this
[Music] foreign you remember what it was like
once relive The Glory Days I only got one
light I want some Marine always a marine and
she's out here I'll find her
where's that hand put her arm around her come
on what are you doing you can make your move
come on
[Music]
just misunderstood John just needs that Ms
Right to come if she sleeps through anything
huh
all that white powder lets her rest easy yeah
oh my gosh she's sucking the youth out of
her what's going on she's a Dementors they
eat her soul
oh nice
pet a little Gator head there
[Music]
ugh damn it man I want to do this and not
oh there's Gators out
[Music] nah you're safe this is a creepy film
[Music] yes arm up [Music] I don't think she's
gonna make it out of this movie alive John
uh uh yeah probably not I just don't want
him to get shot oh [__] woof scare me
pops lunch Marine always a worry I can't give
her what she wants anymore say what flash
bohemian shade here was the same barely any
clothes and Tyson my wife ah they're both
bad yeah we better get back up to the house
and find out what's going on I know exactly
what's going on let's ah
he thinks he's they're intentionally seducing
her whoa
wake up please for the love of God
I'll do that me
here's Jenny oh no no no she gonna have a
brutal ass death you can really feel it
[Applause]
nobody's coming for you get back down in that
stuff be quiet oh there's oh God
will at least expect in good Christian homes
right on the bare noses see they're doing
the gods work right now yeah they're doing
the Lord's work I think everyone we've been
following are the bad guys yep not not these
murderers hiding out in the American Heart
are executing sin that's true extensions of
his grace foreign yes oh my goodness step
away from from The Edge it's dangerous it's
all right here here you're safe now okay okay
it's just crazy you don't suspect that it
did because she's an old ass lady yeah what
about becoming a nurse one day okay oh damn
why should you get to him at all
was there to be able to just flaunt it in
my face like you do it ain't my fault you
didn't live the life you wanted oh move you
mean old ugly [__] right into the gator
[__]
[Music] a flathead Chomp
[Applause] was that the one you know I don't
like blondes ugh they're both evil yeah yeah
that alligator egg crab is that's good that's
visceral that place is empty and I got another
captain of the house for me I don't want her
that's something special or god dude oh I'm
tired and never getting what I want she has
it The X Factor yeah tell me I'm special you
are you're a professional killer yeah I feel
that way since the first moment we met oh
you all romantic so they're like the heart
of the movie yeah you still want me
come on you are way too old to feel young
again I let her have this he's gonna he's
gonna die trying okay
oh man this guy about to die remember the
story of Adam and Eve oh you're gonna have
a heart attack go for it you crazy kids
oh no what a terrible spot to hide oh
oh
yep yep yep [Laughter]
this is maybe the most tense I've ever seen
this Trope done
foreign
no no [Music] Howard about to have a heart
attack get that shotgun blast
stay [Music]
but did she catch work that one of them is
being kept she must have I mean whoa you can
go a little way on a flat tire
oh what oh God okay all right but is it Lotus
I mean I would just run in there really quick
[Music] no need to go about this slowly you
know exactly where the old couple is you know
you have a head start and if he dies I mean
she'll be pinned so
foreign [Applause]
[Music]
there's some very Great Kills in here man
a lot of punch a lot of energy
don't burn upon with the others they're winning
out of the barn is sinking fuel yeah really
good hearing yeah whoa damn her face is messed
up thirsty
no that's what I'm talking about see
are the case to the truck in the kitchen we
have reach the crossroads she'll come out
when people find out what you've done oh I
don't think I know who you really are I thought
what you did in the barn deviant little oh
that doesn't warrant any of this depend on
the flag to me I'm nothing like you you're
kidnapping murdering sex things
I will not accept a lot I do not deserve I
do not deserve wow staring at me [Music] well
you can still hit her at least throw it at
her come on come on whoa whoa kick back irony
nice on those who accept him praise His name
Gloria bit of Jesus I love how they both died
like that that's so funny
that was great
drop kick yeah double tap just to be safe
I'll never play you in a prequel oh dude you're
gonna get your head run over lady
oh lady you're bad come on WOW [Laughter]
[Music]
oh nice [Music] oh with the
crucifix jeez nice wide angle so drive it
to an alligator's mouth
swallow the whole truck
my beautiful little daughter Maxine okay Lord
into a life of sin by the very deviants we
want them here on a daily basis oh she Maxine
yeah that I mean yeah I forgot her name yeah
no she's in the vaccine okay did she know
that was her dad on the TV she must what do
you reckon happened Sheriff how the hell should
I know [Laughter] that's a great answer found
this inside put that in evidence let's see
what goddamn Dove heart picture [Laughter]
wait so is this Pearl movie about Pearl I
guess it must be that I mean there's a Cinematic
Universe I don't know anything about what
you're talking about it's a bad Universe I
don't I mean I I haven't read much intentionally
but I yeah Pearl they like I think started
working on while they were working on this
and like Ty West and like Mia goth like wrote
it together and then there's another third
movie called Maxine with three X's that they're
making now okay so they are actually connected
it's not like the ice cream Brothers
when I
said ice cream Brothers I was like that's
the only connected movies I can think of that
have a strong ice cream thing yeah I can't
remember what I recalled I called the ice
cream Brothers
yeah they call that a trolley Sean of the
dead and and those other two yeah but Spirits
these are these are actual connected yeah
I have no idea how and and why but yeah okay
so she did Play Pearl see okay there you go
yeah you're right about that oh so she probably
came up with the whole backstory for Pearl
and then Tyler's was probably like oh that's
pretty good he wrote it together yeah we can
uh we can make some of that yeah that's that's
gnarly yeah and they like both came out in
the same year I think last like last year
this is the most crowd-pleasing tie West movie
I've ever seen I think it's pretty straightforward
yeah I don't know Ty West's other movies but
there's enough stylistic flourishes and choices
in here to make me think sometimes it does
experimental independent pieces that go a
little too far off the rails for your mainstream
audience to a degree yeah but also that are
like very deliberate and and patient and they
take a while and then they kind of explain
like a house of the devil has that where it's
like this is a very patient movie in the last
20 minutes are insane oh really whereas this
is like a steady build up throughout and like
his VHS segment is like one of the slower
Burns oh [__] well [__] John well
[__] that's a problem you watch a movie
like this and then you want to do a terrible
Southern drawl the rest of the day we're gonna
talk about this the whole goddamn reveals
all right brother preach Yeehaw that'll plug
your time out of there that was the film we
deserved for the lives we deserve gonna get
myself a gator hunting gun damn wow all right
well now we review it alrighty ladies and
gentlemen well while I feel like I gotta digest
it a little bit as we go um yeah it's kind
of interesting I've seen a few horror movies
this year and this this came out 2022 so I'm
not sure exactly where I would particularly
place it I enjoyed it quite a bit you know
I thought it did a really good job at the
first thing that pops to mind for me is I
think it did an excellent job at not only
capturing the aura and the Aesthetics of a
70s horror movie but really using it as more
than just a gimmick it had a had a powerful
affect on the experience overall with its
yeah you have that dirty scuzzy feeling about
it and while it you know evokes a lot of the
70s horror movies as the film plays out it
stops being that and the way they s this director
Ty West did a great job at subverting expectations
in the way how a lot of deaths went down or
even doing some good surprises for certain
things and does a good job of getting you
to pay attention in a way where it's not like
this big murder mystery or something like
that but you know it's it's not till like
close to an hour in until moves about hour
45 and or yeah something about actual film
not counting crowd it's about an hour 45 and
I and I noticed that like it wasn't until
like close to an hour end until the first
death happens but there's constantly building
the the mood it's constantly building this
atmosphere of
this interesting sin and depravity but not
like full-on depravity it's more of just the
uh messed up ways uh this Christian America
can often uh make Society feel and it's uh
which is which is neat to have her be the
daughter I thought of like to grow up in a
household because there's so much types of
Oppression that gets judged and often the
ones who are the ones causing the condemnation
to have those same desires within themselves
and then they retaliate by shaming or like
this is this is like a very extreme version
of that to me you know with this old couple
where I haven't seen this Pearl moved on what
the hell that happens in that Pearl Baxter
but then my interpretation off of this one
Standalone film first off is it you get this
impression of this judgment that they bestow
upon the way Society is today and the youth
and then like these guys are the embodiment
of it they're making an adult film look at
them just having their orgies and indulging
themselves and that their sexual deviant ways
but she desires that and she wants that too
you know yeah and they commit these acts of
violence so it was an interesting it was an
interesting experience because you're you're
so much more in the mood of it all before
[__] starts really going down and I thought
it did a really excellent job because I thought
it was just going to be like a Non-Stop Slaughter
Fest and suddenly in the last half hour where
she's like running fast and all that yeah
yeah we should get Supernatural power yeah
yeah but it never it never divulged into that
because I introduced her as this uh you know
helpless senile lady is very ill and even
I was getting my guesses wrong about like
maybe he's out maybe they're trying to just
trick us like he's all right yeah but she's
she's a cruising one but actually you know
they're both crazy and it's they're the same
people from when they were young where he
just wants to please her and keep her happy
so I thought it was a very fun experience
uh I thought it was really well executed and
disturbing that that wasn't like too disturbing
to me but it was like reasonably disturbing
but it's a yeah it's effective on this story
it's undisturbing it's like Grindhouse horror
to me it wasn't like yeah you know it's really
it's really like pulpy yeah and I like how
it's practical effects driven in that department
too yeah I think they they did nicely in a
couple different ways to split the difference
and yeah have it be they did just the right
amount of tributing to to give you a bunch
of preconceived notions to then tweak and
play with uh you know based off of stuff like
a Texas Chainsaw movie or like a Friday the
13th movie or any number of others and then
they also give you the 70s style to then go
off of but they also mix just the right amount
it's like it's like you said it's not just
like a gimmick or a filter or something they
put over this they use the patience of the
70s Vibe and that directing style and those
lens choices to I think split the difference
in a really nice way because if you watch
a movie like The Texas Chainsaw Massacre that
movie feels like you're there and it's very
spread out in a lot of ways and it's more
violent than you remember it being uh whereas
in a movie like this you know you still have
a lot of that same patience and a lot of that
same atmosphere and a lot of that same you
know you can feel the heat and the stickiness
but I feel like this in a side-by-side comparison
would be more outwardly pleasing in a way
because it is uh paced in a more modern sensibility
it has more of a modern build and so I thought
yeah a while so like a gazillion shots in
style so yeah purely like a 70s film oh yeah
absolutely and again like I I've seen other
movies and other tie West movies even uh very
much adhere to the time and place in cinema
that they are emulating and and speaking the
language of whereas here I thought it was
a really nice splitting of that difference
and that carries over into the gore and the
kills as well because yeah it is like schlocky
and it is like grind Housey and it is like
more 80s in that regard or yeah I mean late
70s works too but yeah you have that sort
of naturalistic approach to like when she
gets her fingers smashed in the door Jenna
Ortega like that's a very icky like real looking
gag but it also plays as this very shocking
very in your face you know thing that in an
earlier time would not look as real would
look a lot more hyper stylized and so I think
they did nicely across a lot of different
parts of this to split that difference to
authentically give you you know that tribute
quality but then use that against you too
those old people did not look real like realistically
old they looked like it was like well I enjoyed
looking at the makeup but they look like so
it's a nitpick I mean I don't know how much
it would really do for me if they did look
real you know but it was like that it's like
such makeup they're so made up yeah it's like
you could tell like oh they both got fake
teeth in and then he's got like his jaw built
way down to look like a Hills Have Eyes character
like if [__] Keepers fell in love with
this [__] yeah yes absolutely yeah that's
great not that it needs to be that real for
me um I don't even know I really want it up
pointed it out but it's just that's just one
thing yeah it's it's something you I noticed
that throughout I was thinking about that
I mean I think that's what it really helped
you guess that thing with me at goth too it's
like there's an awareness that this is not
this makeup is so he is very much makeup yeah
and it's funny because part way through I
was like oh wow like they're really drawing
this mystery like they're not showing their
faces very much what's going on and then part
way through like okay as a country interest
decision because it's creepy but also it helps
these makeups yeah yeah well I think the movie
is so much about our I like okay look get
out of the way everyone does a great job acting
ones thought everyone was great you know and
I like I like these horror movies that are
always a two halves like you got one half
of this movie which only intermittently checks
in with the old people but the first half
is them making an adult film and the uncomfortable
situations that can occur with that but are
kind of thematically linked with Jenna Ortega's
character because so much of it is is so much
Christian America's unhealthy relationship
with sexuality you know and her character
is like they call her the church girl church
mouse yeah church mouse church mouse she's
the one who walks around wearing the crucifix
around her neck like she's a good Christian
girl and and it's her desire for you know
the lustful desire that comes out of her which
the moments preceding the time where she um
lets out that she wants to be a part of the
adult film where everyone's talking about
like yeah this is like old ways of thinking
and it's and you know in 2023 today it's like
uh polyamorous relationships are so common
now especially out here in L.A like they're
they're very cool yeah it's very common now
yeah and and it's something that you know
I obviously can still have a very big stigma
around it and then a lot of people can feel
uncomfortable to like open up about it or
or be honest if they are on one or something
like that uh because uh just because the way
the world is right and so when they're with
that group they're all talking about it like
they just love sexy and then with her character
going down that change and then watching it
tear apart the relationship I like how that
ends up being the Segway piece into the full-blown
horror with the old couple who has this thing
that the sexual desire that morphs into violence
yeah which is which is such a like the religious
thing was so overt but it became such a such
a such a presence throughout even though the
movie wasn't even about religion but it is
yeah yeah and I like that you know by the
end of it it's like it sets you up in a way
where you expect certain characters will be
rewarded or punished for certain things and
I think it does nicely yeah to not leave you
there ultimately because it's like it's like
church mouse makes it almost to the end and
the guy who is the least involved in what
the community around him is doing is the first
one to go and yeah like I thought this had
a i this is a movie that I would want to chew
on and kind of digest more because I think
they're there's so much of it that's just
kind of your straightforward watching events
unfold but there is I think an interesting
human comment because I I did feel for the
old couple in a way because yeah I mean they
have these really restrictive beliefs but
also they are just like past the prime of
of life and longing for you know the the spoils
and splendors of being young and what that
affords you and uh and some of that is very
tragic uh and and that sort of personal tragedy
then bleeding over into this yeah religious
Dogma that I think is nicely like poked at
and prodded without ever feeling like it's
preacher like it's you know like I'm watching
somebody do a diatribe but through characters
or something like that like this plays really
well as its own movie Just experience alone
and it doesn't seem to pass too much judgment
on any one character uh which I think is kind
of a nice thing because then that allows you
to bring your own you know Rorschach test
psychology in and kind of extrapolate as as
you please and as you want and I mean I think
the only thing you can kind of predict going
in is like most everybody will probably die
somehow but the way that all goes down I thought
was was interestingly handled and it didn't
feel too much like it felt like the situation
going to [__] and then you finding what
Twisted underbelly Lies Beneath all this stuff
and like you were pointing out yeah like you
know people who are watching this on TV all
the time yet are harboring these latent desires
that are just festering and rotting and boiling
over and I think having them be old these
two like is you know extremely old and kind
of you know stylized looking people then coming
together and actually making love to one another
and having that not be the thing that kills
them but it gets them kind of close to there
like I think it flirts with those things that
people imagine when Jenna Ortega runs out
she she has that turn where she's like you're
the cause of all this this is all your fault
like she almost has this turn back into the
extremes of her faithfulness because it's
it's almost kind of uh resigning to the idea
that like God is punishing us right now because
of my Temptation because of you guys because
We snuck in here and had to do all this and
yeah and yeah it it I think it just gets at
that fulcrum of pleasure that can either Empower
or rot you you know one way or another and
I think it is interesting that she is the
you know I guess you could argue that she
is an escapee from this particular sect of
Christianity that is all over these TVs that
is just like so prevalent and I think that's
kind of a neat thing for that character because
I guess you always have to question I don't
know anything surrounding sexual empowerment
that is like authored by a dude is like something
I think you know needs a certain amount of
like an examination but it is kind of interesting
that yeah she is you know well entrenched
in you know the the industry that we're spending
most of the first half of the movie looking
through the lens of and yet she's also having
this direct reaction to a different kind of
Oppression that's masquerading as something
Pious whereas here it's like on the face this
is like yeah this is a sin this is sexual
deviance all that stuff and yet you know when
we peer in on them there's kind of regular
people you know trying to make a life for
themselves and I think that's the nice thing
about that Mantra I don't want to live the
life I want to live the life I deserve or
whatever I won't live life I don't deserve
and her repurposing that for her own empowerment
yeah that's an interesting twist yeah I wonder
how I feel about that twist yeah yeah like
I mean it gives you a kind of an Insight a
little bit more to like ruminating on what
her backstory would be it is just uh I don't
know I I really don't know how I really don't
know if I even really like like oh cool but
is it a little too clever I'm not really sure
I'm curious like the twist might be like a
little too much for me I don't know if it
is though it might reach there's again I think
there's a certain uh they're not doing too
much magic with the circumstances Everything
feels very natural and that is one of those
things that feels the most coincidental I
guess or the most it's the detail that is
placed in a way where you can most feel beyond
the camera instead of just what's happening
on screen that's a good way to put it down
yeah and that's that's the thing I would be
curious to again digest and stuff like I I
like it's it's difficult in this position
because you want to have a fully formed opinion
you know right away but this is one of those
movies that I would want to sit with for the
theme's sake because the ending the way the
ending goes down part of me is like you could
look at this as just a new twist or a new
way to you have your classic slasher final
girl but she is even further from like there
was a time where it was kind of progressive
to have it be that like it wasn't just the
virginal girl who makes it to the end like
maybe there is a girl who does indulge a bit
throughout the movie but she still kind of
is okay and she makes it and in this one it's
like you know she's you know the whole like
you can't have sex and make it through the
movie rules out the window but she's also
like you know she takes a bump at the end
as well and it's like you know she's still
kind of steeped in all these things I think
a character would be punished for if the movie
had actually come out during this time um
oh yeah I mean I don't think the movie's on
the side of yeah Christian America no yeah
no but but at the same time it doesn't seem
entirely just like religion bad and that's
it you know like I feel like at least the
way it presents itself gives you again a little
more latitude to consider you know the themes
yeah no I I think they don't it doesn't become
like protagonists arguing about religion yeah
they call her church mouse and stuff but in
the whole discussion about sexuality before
uh Jenner Ortega's character decides she wants
to be on camera there's not uh I don't think
there's anything about God in that moment
yeah that was that guy's personal boundary
yeah there's nothing wrong about Christianity
but but that's the thing is there's so there's
there's so much of a and it's still evolving
in this world you know and it's a in America
especially it's it's so evolving and there
is such an uncomfortableness that a lot of
us kind of grow up with every time I go into
the sauna oh it happened today there's always
some like random guys just talking about it
and like what our kids are growing up with
like I'm like this is why is it always in
the song like there's always like random guys
I've never seen the same guy twice
and the kind of society you're growing up
in you know uh it's because yeah I mean even
even the director of the Wayne director talks
about like the time in which this movie's
taking place places before people could just
access adult films you know in their comfortability
of your own homes they're not exclusive to
just the creeps you know perverts whatever
yeah you don't have to be bold enough to go
to a theater yeah yeah now you can just everyone
can indulge it everyone has it in them at
the end of the day you know and it's that
I I like the story of someone who wants I
like the idea of like this is all a form of
repression just manifesting itself in some
weird way yeah you know and and even for even
even for the general take advantage I mean
a goth character Maxine like in some ways
or her upbringing is so much about hers you
can imagine I like the Twister what it tells
you about the character of Maxine growing
up in what must have been the strictest Christian
household yeah and preacher's daughter so
much of being judged and being told you're
not good enough and what you're doing is a
sin you're wrong you're going to go to hell
you're going to be punished and and so much
of this is a uh an act going against that
and learning to be okay with yourself doing
all that you know and so I I appreciate that
I do miss for uh some of the kind of I don't
like uh this movie John I'd very much disagree
on uh I don't like that Texas Chainsaw Massacre
original movie I don't I have a really hard
time sitting through it I actually think it's
a very frustrating film and and uh but what
I do like is the element of the very end of
the relief that the final girl has after the
the crazy turbo oil this woman has been through
and this desperation to survive and then when
she gets away like it's such an iconic shot
in cinema when she's on the back of the truck
for a reason you know I'm like oh she did
it look up there's all these like variety
of emotions running through her and I and
and and for me I do kind of need that what
a main character gets away after all their
friends die is something that seems like I
just went through hell and granted she didn't
see like all the dead bodies and whatever
but she's probably picked up on the fact that
all are all dead you know but she's been through
a horror show and there was a bit of a missing
and which is crazy to me because Mia goth
did such an amazing job yeah throughout the
film and as the old lady like such an amazing
job but the the movie didn't have that button
for me of her having just dealt with like
just the most horrific experience and as much
as there's like these empowering qualities
uh a part that pulls me out is you just did
kind of go through like the craziest horror
show in the world right now if I was the director
and she was just a little too cool for school
at the end of it for me if I was the director
I would have done a lot one of those one of
those things they they sometimes used to do
back in the day whereas you do your credits
over a long shot and just let her drive what
the credits play as she's driving and just
like breaking down maybe she's still you know
it takes whatever she needs but but yeah it
is a little bit like hell yeah I just made
it I'm a badass I'm a badass yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm going out to be a star still
and I'm leaving this all behind me and I think
you could do that I think you could still
have that but I I feel like part of your blender
that other quality ought to have been mixed
in a little bit more because yeah but she
I mean when she when uh when Bobby Lynn comes
in and she's like she was in my bed and she
was touching me like she seemed really rattled
and and yeah like rightfully so just a little
bit of that on that ending shot would have
been yeah nice yeah instead of just she's
a badass yeah badass or or you know even if
you argue she's in shock she still kind of
comes to cry I feel like you know the movie
is putting it across to you like but she's
kind of a badass though yeah yeah no I I think
you can do Disturbed but badass I think definitely
yeah I think I'm saying like I want to say
sacrifice the quality that they had saying
Implement with you know we're in agreement
yeah just add a little bit more of that that
shakenness that we have seen up until this
point yeah yeah that's the that's one part
of it um but the actors are all good I thought
everyone was very natural and um and and uh
they all brought something to the role like
there's all kinds of Arc types in here but
they didn't feel like archetypes which I really
appreciated yeah like they they really could
have you know and I think for a movie that's
riffing on slasher films which generally have
the Trope of like these people going out and
fornicating and how hot they're about to get
killed I like how that's such a part of meat
and part of the story it's it's part of the
literally thematically what you're dealing
with in this entire story uh so I thought
that was real I really appreciate that and
I think for every character that they had
here who was part of the film crew they they
managed to make everyone feel very natural
with writing and performances and no one felt
like they were just playing stereotypes when
they really it really could have been that
like you actually literally got one black
guy like you could you could have just been
a very stereotypical oh yeah yeah a marine
baby yeah yeah yeah you could have played
him like an actual 70s Wawa thing yeah and
Brittany so could've just been like blonde
ditzy girl or whatever yeah it's like you
can tell these are actual people felt like
people yeah they feel like people yeah Brittany
Snow's got Ambitions Kid Cudi like you know
he feels that character I was like yeah I
buy that I buy that he's you know this ex-marine
who's yeah well they're still in his prime
to a degree well I think they flesh out the
relationships pretty well too I mean even
for the Howard not Howard um Wayne for the
Wayne character you know I feel like in another
movie he just would have been like oh you
find out he's just some douchey God he wants
to bang all the other girls I can't wait to
watch his sleeves die yeah yeah he turns into
just some like creep sleazy dude and you really
get the idea like no I mean I respect what
my woman does and uh but yeah I got a business
owner I do want to run business but you also
get the idea that he cares like everyone felt
the relationships all worked for me even even
Jenna Ortega and the boyfriend the guy filming
like I thought that all all that worked really
well it was a solid conflict so I think for
a film that managed to do a thing that was
riffing on a certain type of genre and era
they did bring something unique to it and
felt natural and it was really well executed
movie that I feel like my appreciation for
will probably just grow over time with like
literally a couple of things that I'm questionable
about how I feel about it yeah no yeah as
I think a really good convergence of classic
and modern sensibility and uh and yeah something
that has sort of Timeless questions but also
questions themes that are very pertinent to
the right here and now and yeah I think it
does also well to again set you up with certain
preconceived notions it's like old people
and these kinds of movies are always just
wallpaper to make everything creepier but
here they're like actually characters after
a while and yeah even though you are about
to watch a bunch of teens or Young people-ish
making love and then dying it's not in the
exact same package as you would expect it
and even the little peripheral things like
the alligators was a great touch just like
a great sort of Hazard of the environment
what is an alligator for the elevator versus
crocodile what is an alligator alligator represent
yes let's do that and wisdom Primal instincts
Good Fortune how do we how do we read into
the use of an alligator uh I guess well you
know there's plenty of uh Primal Instinct
ancient wisdom all the all the religious themes
ancient religious themes yeah yes yes uh I'm
not having the wrong word symbolism I get
her symbolism all right all right
uh okay or they can really present like a
threat as spirit animals and civilized individuality
protection and strength I guess that one works
after the 15 different editions we have alligators
in front of us yeah yeah just trying to protect
each other or he was just like well they were
by a
[Laughter] know this is the thing you'd have
to look out for a good Death kill yeah and
also mad respect uh to how they handle the
kills because even though you know they're
gonna die it's also uh uh they would surprise
because that like I think the one that surprised
me the most because yeah you have some good
jump scare ones the one that surprised me
the most was the death of Wayne because it
goes into his eye and it's just funny yeah
but then when it clap but when it cuts back
I'm like I've never had that before like a
like a cut back to it and it's just being
pulled out yeah like something you've already
seen happen sure and and the jump scares not
him getting and jabbing in the high the jump
scares are getting pulled out like that that
was really creative yeah yeah absolutely and
like they do again like it's it's another
one of those it's a classic kill and yeah
it's the classic kind of kill you would cut
away from and that's it yeah and then yeah
you get you get the whole aftermath and she
buries him and it just gives you so much extra
little hint as to what really is happening
here well also yeah like keeping the body
count feeling fresh you know definitely for
the here and now and yeah uh like really really
effective in terms of kills and jump scares
and stuff like that like nothing felt there
weren't really anywhere I was like ah cheap
you know and I and I don't know if it's a
direct reference to any movie but I actually
really liked that that strange one two three
and now we actually cut to the next scene
or the other you know place that we're alluding
to I thought that editing transition they
kept doing was was an interesting flourish
well it makes it feel like overlap because
it is overlapping in a way but it's really
inner cutting but I did learn recently that
like back then it was so much harder to add
when you're dealing with film a lot of times
directors wouldn't even know what the a dissolve
or a fade whatever might look like until the
film was out it's such a process now you could
just like drop it in your iMovie you know
it's like really easy and uh so but back then
with film so I appreciate they didn't do any
of that [__] here yeah it was like well
and I wonder if because it adds a certain
there is a mood to it and it gives it a bit
of an ethereal touch so uh but it's their
time like from an understanding filmmaking
a little bit I I'm like I wonder if they chose
just you know not to do any type of Fades
because of that yeah you know and he makes
that comment about like I can take the footage
I can put it in any order I want you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah so even though it's not
like directly like oh he must have vetted
this like there is yeah I think it pairs nicely
with the tangibility of the filmmaking but
I would have loved if it was the actual final
shot of the movie was while she's driving
the film you know real though yeah close this
out and then it cuts to and it's RJ at the
editing booth and he's like well what do you
think of the film do you think this is more
RC of more entertaining is this an elevated
adult film or not yeah it's just with the
whole
caste via Gotham like her makeup and her Old
Woman makeup well and for a second there I
was like well if any gum actress is playing
you know is playing maybe uh maybe the guy
who plays Wayne is playing Howard or something
you know what if there's some like time timeline
thing yeah yeah conversions of time happening
here at once either that or I would have loved
if if just afterwards you know it's like cut
to the Evans evidence room and some cop is
like I cut together the footage they got would
you like to see yeah just play the actual
porno all right like Super 8 or something
um alrighty guys well thank you for being
here I really appreciate um everyone who suggested
this wild film yeah it was fun and hey we
will uh what was today's what day are we filming
this is and then we'll just end this video
right now we'll talk with you all soon thank
you for being here [Music]